[Música]
hola gracias por continuar en la
pantalla de france 24 y bienvenidos a 5
minutos con en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña mariana zafón la directora
colombiana que se lució en el festival
de cine de venecia con el premio
horizontes a mejor cortometraje por su
obra llamada entre tú y milagro mariana
zafón muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france en 24 cuéntenos que
representó para usted y también para la
población colombiana donde se rodó este
corto el hecho de haber ganado este
premio
pues muchas gracias por invitarme al
programa y pues muy felices esto es una
celebración a todo el trabajo de todo el
equipo y obviamente a un país es un
reconocimiento muy grande es un esfuerzo
increíble de todo el equipo estamos muy
felices por este reconocimiento de
verdad su cuarto habla acerca de la
separación entre una madre y su hija que
tuvo la historia de particular quiere
usted para convencer al jurado
pues yo pienso que es una historia que
más que ser solo la historia de esta
madre esta hija es se siente como la
vida como un pedacito de la vida de
milagros su protagonista donde ella está
pasando por un momento de en su
adolescencia donde ella se está
separando digamos de lo que ella era de
su infancia y su relación con su mamá
y al mismo tiempo su mamá en un momento
distinto como mujer donde ya está
digamos que volviendo a querer hacer su
vida después de estar divorciado durante
muchos años y esos dos momentos son los
que colapsan
de estas dos mujeres que digamos las dos
buscan el amor pero en distintos lugares
de la historia es autobiográfica tiene
algo de real la historia
pues no es autobiográfica pero yo pienso
que todas las historias que uno cuenta
como director tienen mucho aparte de la
idea hace de preventa que existan en uno
y digamos que podría cumplir 30 años me
di cuenta que mi mamá a los 30 años ya
tenía una hija de 2 años que era yo y ya
está energía y en ese momento me puse a
pensar y decir yo nunca había pensado en
mi mamá claro
y me puse a pensar en las relaciones de
mamá hija y lo que uno espera a las
mujeres una vez se convierten en mamás
como un no niega hasta de mujer que pues
que debe continuar con la vida de esta
mujer entonces ahí fue que empecé a
crear la historia el mundo si es mi
mundo es también una pregunta a mi
privilegio
digamos que esta sociedad colombiana
donde existe una una diferencia de
clases abismal y donde donde hemos
normalizado dinámicas con esto que son
casi violentas para mí y era una
historia donde donde yo estaba
reflexionando también como milagros
desde su burbuja del privilegio se
acerca un poco al conflicto de su país
pero desde el 7 donde leyó y con con la
con la pregunta digamos de su existencia
por su normal
ahora usted hizo una campaña de
crowdfunding verdad cuéntenos por qué y
qué fue lo que consiguió
y bueno pues hacer un cortometraje de
este nivel siempre había sido un
proyecto muy ambicioso y sabíamos que
necesitábamos muchísima ayuda para poder
lograrlo teníamos escenas muy grandes
teníamos una procesión teníamos escenas
en el río con muchos niños extras era
era un comentario muy grande entonces
muy o sea nos ganamos el fondo de
desarrollo cinematográfico colombiano y
con eso nos pudimos ir la producción
pero pero era un proyecto tan grande y
estábamos rodando en cine que
necesitábamos un impulso a más para
poder terminar este proyecto entonces
decidimos hacer una campaña de cauto
anding con la cual conseguimos los
últimos fondos para poder también quedar
la postproducción la compra de música
sonido toda esa parte y pues gracias a
la ayuda de muchísima gente pudimos
terminar nuestra película y no quedar
muy pocos segundos 30 más o menos pero
quiero preguntarte que se viene ahora
que viene ahora pues ahora estoy
trabajando en mi largometraje que se
llama la botero es
un poco conectado con el mundo de entre
tú y milagros y pues esto este premio si
es un impulso muy grande para que haya
interés en este largo interés en mí como
directora entonces trabajando durísimo
este sólo es el comienzo y el premio
sólo es un impulso para poder seguir
trabajando fuertemente así que
muchísimas gracias a mariana zafón por
tu presencia en france 24 a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a continuar
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]